situation confuse à kiev à kiev la
capitale est désertée combien de temps
la ville peut-elle tenir les russes
tentent de prendre la capitale le siège
a débuté selon ministre de la santé
ukrainien on compte près de 200 morts au
sol des combats ont opposé les forces
russes et ukrainiennes sur l'avenue de
la victoire l'une des artères
principales de la capitale les habitants
ont passé la nuit dans des abris on
retrouve tout de suite clovis casali
notre envoyé spécial quelle est la
situation les ukrainiens sont prêts à se
défendre et à résister
absolument et on entend encore des
détonations
aujourd'hui la nuit a été très compliqué
pour la première fois on a entendu des
tirs nourris ici depuis le centre ville
de kiev nuit très compliqué les sirènes
ont retenti et bien sûr les ukrainiens
se sont rués dont les abris à souterrain
pour se protéger des bombardements
aériens russes possible alors un missile
vous l'avez dit a frappé un immeuble
résidentiel proche d'un aéroport qui se
situe à à peine 6 km de l'épicentre de
kiev on ne connaît pas encore le nombre
de victimes ni le nombre de blessés les
ukrainiens dystocie qu'à 30 km de la
capitale et bien il y à des combats
violents entre les soldats ukrainiens et
les troupes russes au sol des
parachutistes russes un bilan avec au
moins 200 morts côté ukrainien pour
l'instant et de nombreux blessés et
selon des témoignages et bien dans les
hôpitaux militaires il y a beaucoup
d'ukrainiens qui vont donner leur sang
pour le bleu pour les banques de sang et
pour aider les blessés
situation encore très volatile
aujourd'hui à kiev mais les ukrainiens
tiennent bon merci beaucoup clovis
casali